This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。品质保证真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都算不上安全的坦诚对话，但你是在跟一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.|||在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是 Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.|||这就是在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上播出的《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.|||他会得到他应得的下场。我们总说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和说是个大日子。84年对我也意义重大。我是 Sam J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我是 Alex English。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如 Mark Lamont Hill 谈论 80 年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost nonstop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost nonstop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me|||大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身处世界哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听另一期节目。不过，正如你们可能已经注意到的那样，今天的节目是一期重播。因此，在接下来的两周里，我将发布过去四年几乎不间断录制播客中的一些最佳单集，因为我要抽出一小段时间去推出我的处女作《Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of your 20s》（成长中的人：你二十岁心理学指南）。不用担心，我将于 4 月 29 日回归，但我只是想在接下来的两周里给我的书多一点关爱，因为这是一件大事，而且我不会过多谈论它。我确信你们只是来听播客的，可能也厌倦了我
talking about it, but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. Literally, that's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me. So just thank you. Thank you so much. I would obviously love it. If you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much, and I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. Most of all, I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it.
talking about it, but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. Literally, that's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me. So just thank you. Thank you so much. I would obviously love it. If you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much, and I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. Most of all, I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it.|||谈论它，但我只想说谢谢。我要非常感谢你们允许我写这本书并将其带到世界上。这一切之所以可能，完全是因为你们所有人，因为你们这些听客。真的，就是这样。这是我能够做到这一点的唯一原因。我从五岁起就想成为一名作家，20年后。是你们帮我实现了这个愿望。所以，谢谢你们。非常感谢。如果你们能预订、购买或把它作为礼物送给朋友，我当然会很高兴。但你们已经做得够多了，能有这个机会我深感荣幸。最重要的是，我真的非常期待你们能读到它。
I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love Person in Progress as well. But it's a really exciting time. And the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much. Without further ado, I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk
I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love Person in Progress as well. But it's a really exciting time. And the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much. Without further ado, I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk|||我希望你们能有所收获。我确信，如果你喜欢这个播客，你也会喜欢《Person in Progress》。但这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻。我现在主要感受到的就是感激。所以非常感谢你们。闲话少说，希望大家喜欢这期我最喜欢的历史单集的重播。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，在这里我们探讨
through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to this show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. back and for another topic as we break down the psychology of our 20s. When we think about our 20s, I think there are four things that we worry about more than anything else. We worry about love, we worry about money, the future, and finally our friendships.
through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to this show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. back and for another topic as we break down the psychology of our 20s. When we think about our 20s, I think there are four things that we worry about more than anything else. We worry about love, we worry about money, the future, and finally our friendships.|||我们二十岁时经历的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到本节目，欢迎回到本播客，新听友、老听友，无论你们身处世界哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听另一期节目。欢迎回来，我们将探讨另一个话题，剖析我们二十岁的心理学。当我们想到二十岁时，我认为有四件事是我们比任何事情都更担心的。我们担心爱情、担心金钱、担心未来，最后是我们的友谊。
Today we're really going to focus in on that final point there and examine the way that our friendships change during this decade and why despite a lot of the fear and our anxiety and our discomfort, this experience is totally normal. It's natural and it's going to be okay. Every one of us has had to witness as someone they were once really close to slowly kind of drips away, replies to their messages less and less, finds new friends who are maybe better for them whilst you're left feeling a little bit discarded. a little bit unmoored, or maybe you are the friend who has moved on, and you're coming to terms with the realization that you have outgrown the people who are once your closest friends.
Today we're really going to focus in on that final point there and examine the way that our friendships change during this decade and why despite a lot of the fear and our anxiety and our discomfort, this experience is totally normal. It's natural and it's going to be okay. Every one of us has had to witness as someone they were once really close to slowly kind of drips away, replies to their messages less and less, finds new friends who are maybe better for them whilst you're left feeling a little bit discarded. a little bit unmoored, or maybe you are the friend who has moved on, and you're coming to terms with the realization that you have outgrown the people who are once your closest friends.|||今天，我们将真正聚焦于最后一点，审视我们的友谊在这十年中是如何改变的，以及为什么尽管有许多恐惧、焦虑和不安，这种经历完全是正常的。这是自然的，一切都会好起来的。我们每个人都曾目睹过，某个曾经非常亲密的人慢慢疏远，回复信息越来越少，找到了可能更适合他们的新朋友，而你却觉得自己被抛弃了，感到有些迷茫和无依无靠；或者也许你才是那个向前看的朋友，并且开始接受这样一个现实：你已经超越了曾经最亲密的朋友。
The friendship group has disbanded, your friend's just got a new partner. There are so many ways that we see our friendships change. And it's scary because those relationships are really what hold us up during this decade as we slowly kind of separate away from the security of the family unit, and we're trying to form our own identity. Having a broad set of friends in those moments to really rely on and call upon is super vital. And it's also really vital for our mental health. There's been so many studies that have shown that people who have close friends, close confidence, they're more satisfied with their lives, they're less likely to suffer from depression. They overall just feel happier.
The friendship group has disbanded, your friend's just got a new partner. There are so many ways that we see our friendships change. And it's scary because those relationships are really what hold us up during this decade as we slowly kind of separate away from the security of the family unit, and we're trying to form our own identity. Having a broad set of friends in those moments to really rely on and call upon is super vital. And it's also really vital for our mental health. There's been so many studies that have shown that people who have close friends, close confidence, they're more satisfied with their lives, they're less likely to suffer from depression. They overall just feel happier.|||朋友圈解散了，你的朋友刚交了新伴侣。我们看到友谊发生改变的方式有那么多。这很可怕，因为这些关系确实支撑着我们度过这十年，在我们慢慢脱离家庭的安全感、试图形成自己的身份认同之际。在那些时刻，拥有一群能够真正依靠和呼唤的广泛朋友是超级重要的。这对我们的心理健康也至关重要。有那么多研究表明，拥有亲密朋友、亲密知己的人对生活更满意，患抑郁症的可能性更小。他们总体上感觉更快乐。
and in contrast, people with poor quality friendships or no friends, they are twice as likely to die prematurely, of course, they suffer increased loneliness. So maintaining a really healthy, broad, fulfilling network of friendships is undoubtedly important. And it's not just about the fact that they provide us with comfort and are obviously massive contributors to our health, but friendship is also just one of the greatest joys in life, right? There are genuinely friends I consider family who know more about me than any partner of mine ever has who make me laugh beyond reason. That connection is so deep that we never want it to fade.
and in contrast, people with poor quality friendships or no friends, they are twice as likely to die prematurely, of course, they suffer increased loneliness. So maintaining a really healthy, broad, fulfilling network of friendships is undoubtedly important. And it's not just about the fact that they provide us with comfort and are obviously massive contributors to our health, but friendship is also just one of the greatest joys in life, right? There are genuinely friends I consider family who know more about me than any partner of mine ever has who make me laugh beyond reason. That connection is so deep that we never want it to fade.|||相比之下，友谊质量差或没有朋友的人，过早死亡的可能性是前者的两倍，当然，他们也会承受更多的孤独感。因此，维持一个真正健康、广泛、充实的友谊网络无疑是至关重要的。这不仅因为它们为我们提供慰藉，显然也是我们健康的巨大贡献者，而且友谊本身就是生活中最大的乐趣之一，对吧？确实有一些我视为家人的朋友，他们比我任何伴侣都更了解我，他们能让我毫无理由地开怀大笑。这种联系如此深厚，以至于我们永远不希望它褪色。
In fact, I think we never consider the fact that it might, it will. That is not where our brain naturally goes to the conclusion of the friendship. Because unlike romantic relationships, I think friendships aren't meant to have an expiry date. They aren't meant to go up in flames. There isn't meant to be a breakup. We're not meant to fall out of love with our friends. That is kind of the beauty of platonic intimacy and connection. It's meant to outlast a lot of other forms of love.
In fact, I think we never consider the fact that it might, it will. That is not where our brain naturally goes to the conclusion of the friendship. Because unlike romantic relationships, I think friendships aren't meant to have an expiry date. They aren't meant to go up in flames. There isn't meant to be a breakup. We're not meant to fall out of love with our friends. That is kind of the beauty of platonic intimacy and connection. It's meant to outlast a lot of other forms of love.|||事实上，我认为我们从不考虑它可能会、也终究会褪色这一点。这不是我们的大脑对友谊终结的自然推导。因为与恋爱关系不同，我认为友谊不应该有保质期。它们不应该付之一炬。不应该有分手这回事。我们不应该不再爱我们的朋友。这正是柏拉图式亲密关系和连接的美妙之处。它注定比许多其他形式的爱更长久。
So it comes as a shock when we begin to notice our relationships really shifting or drifting apart from people or realizing that we have mutually outgrown each other or just need space. And a lot of the time, our instinct is to A, blame ourselves, or B, panic. Immediately jump to the worst case scenario. What if I lose all my friends and I end up alone? We don't give ourselves the grace or the permission in these moments of transition to understand that some friendships just have a shorter life cycle and our friendscape is naturally going to shift with age and time.
So it comes as a shock when we begin to notice our relationships really shifting or drifting apart from people or realizing that we have mutually outgrown each other or just need space. And a lot of the time, our instinct is to A, blame ourselves, or B, panic. Immediately jump to the worst case scenario. What if I lose all my friends and I end up alone? We don't give ourselves the grace or the permission in these moments of transition to understand that some friendships just have a shorter life cycle and our friendscape is naturally going to shift with age and time.|||因此，当我们开始注意到我们的关系真正发生转变、与他人渐行渐远，或者意识到我们彼此共同超越了对方、亦或是仅仅需要空间时，我们会感到震惊。很多时候，我们的本能是 A，责怪自己，或者 B，恐慌。立刻跳到最坏的情况。如果我失去了所有的朋友，最后孤身一人怎么办？在这些过渡的时刻，我们没有给自己足够的包容或允许去理解，有些友谊的生命周期就是比较短，我们的朋友圈会随着年龄和时间的推移而自然地发生变化。
And I think that reaction, that entire sequence of events and realizations, is what we're really talking about today, along with all of the psychology that I think comes with watching our friendships change in our 20s. We are going to explore the why, including the literal scientific formula for friendship, the types of friendship endings from the fizzle to the replacement or the breakup, how intensity may actually shorten the life. lifespan of our friendships and the impact of simply just entering into a new chapter of your life and dealing with some of the loneliness that might come along with that. I think there are a lot of friendship misconceptions that keep us stuck in really, really draining relationships. You know, am I a bad person if I don't want to be friends with this person anymore? Am I toxic because all of my friends have kind of moved away and stopped talking to me. Am I boring? How am I going to adapt to this new reality? There is so much to discuss here, especially since I think it is so universal. It is such
And I think that reaction, that entire sequence of events and realizations, is what we're really talking about today, along with all of the psychology that I think comes with watching our friendships change in our 20s. We are going to explore the why, including the literal scientific formula for friendship, the types of friendship endings from the fizzle to the replacement or the breakup, how intensity may actually shorten the life. lifespan of our friendships and the impact of simply just entering into a new chapter of your life and dealing with some of the loneliness that might come along with that. I think there are a lot of friendship misconceptions that keep us stuck in really, really draining relationships. You know, am I a bad person if I don't want to be friends with this person anymore? Am I toxic because all of my friends have kind of moved away and stopped talking to me. Am I boring? How am I going to adapt to this new reality? There is so much to discuss here, especially since I think it is so universal. It is such|||我认为这种反应、这一整串事件和感悟，正是我们今天真正要讨论的内容，连同我认为在二十岁见证友谊改变时随之而来的所有心理学。我们将探讨原因，包括友谊的字面科学公式，友谊终结的类型（从逐渐淡出到被取代或分手），高强度如何实际上会缩短我们友谊的寿命。寿命以及仅仅进入生活的新篇章并应对随之而来的某些孤独感的影响。我认为有很多关于友谊的误解，让我们陷入非常非常消耗精力的关系中。你知道的，如果我不想再和这个人做朋友了，我是个坏人吗？我是有毒的吗，因为我的所有朋友都搬走了，不再跟我说话了。我很无聊吗？我将如何适应这个新现实？这里有太多东西要讨论了，尤其是因为我认为这是如此普遍。这是如此
an important experience to explore because it is inherently isolating. So we don't find ourselves talking about it enough, which is to say in the midst of a massive friendship transition that I'm sure we are all experiencing, I really hope this helps you. I hope that this gives you a sense of guidance. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why our friendships change and why that is totally okay. This past year for me has been a period of like rapid transition. And with that, there's been this real shift in who I spend my time with, the friendships I have. And unfortunately, it's required a lot of reflecting on some of the people that I've seen fade away from my life and kind of feeling a little bit like my friendship circle is unbalanced.
an important experience to explore because it is inherently isolating. So we don't find ourselves talking about it enough, which is to say in the midst of a massive friendship transition that I'm sure we are all experiencing, I really hope this helps you. I hope that this gives you a sense of guidance. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why our friendships change and why that is totally okay. This past year for me has been a period of like rapid transition. And with that, there's been this real shift in who I spend my time with, the friendships I have. And unfortunately, it's required a lot of reflecting on some of the people that I've seen fade away from my life and kind of feeling a little bit like my friendship circle is unbalanced.|||一段值得探索的重要经历，因为它本质上具有孤立性。所以我们发现我们对它的讨论还不够，也就是说，在经历一场我相信我们都在经历的巨大友谊转变之中，我真心希望这能帮到你。我希望这能给你一种指引。废话不多说，让我们进入友谊为什么会改变以及为什么这完全正常的背后心理学。过去对我来说是快速转变的一年。随之而来的是，我陪伴的对象、我拥有的友谊都发生了真正的转变。不幸的是，这需要我反思一些我看到从我生活中淡出的人，并且感觉我的朋友圈有点失衡。
The true biggest factors for me, I think, in that change has been firstly seeing a lot of my friends move away from the city where we kind of all grew to new each other when we were at university. We all went to university at Canberra and I was talking to my boyfriend about this the other day but I think the reason I've been feeling really isolated is because as we like enter into our, I think early and mid-20s in particular, a lot of people choose to scatter. A lot of people move away. And of the people that I'm closest to, one now lives in Paris, one lives in London, one lives in Tasmania, which is like a kind of semi-regional island off of Australia.
The true biggest factors for me, I think, in that change has been firstly seeing a lot of my friends move away from the city where we kind of all grew to new each other when we were at university. We all went to university at Canberra and I was talking to my boyfriend about this the other day but I think the reason I've been feeling really isolated is because as we like enter into our, I think early and mid-20s in particular, a lot of people choose to scatter. A lot of people move away. And of the people that I'm closest to, one now lives in Paris, one lives in London, one lives in Tasmania, which is like a kind of semi-regional island off of Australia.|||我认为，对我来说，这种改变中最大的真正因素，首先是看到我的许多朋友搬离了我们上大学时共同成长并结识彼此的城市。我们都在堪培拉上大学，前几天我还在和男友谈论这件事，但我认为我一直感到非常孤立的原因是，当我们进入，特别是我认为的二十岁出头和二十岁中期时，许多人选择四散各方。很多人搬走了。在我最亲近的人中，现在一个住在巴黎，一个住在伦敦，一个住在塔斯马尼亚，那是澳大利亚海岸外的一个半区域性岛屿。
You know, one of them is in Nepal and everyone just makes the decision that's best for them. They move on with their lives. And that means that each of us is feeling, I think, you need. very isolated. That distance is naturally going to change kind of the dynamic because you don't have that same proximity and the ease or access to this other person. It requires more of an investment. And if you're not willing to keep that up, you have to be willing to see that friendship fizzle out a little bit, not be what it once was or kind of hope that they return. And it's one of those magical moments where it's kind of right back to normal. So I think that's like the first
You know, one of them is in Nepal and everyone just makes the decision that's best for them. They move on with their lives. And that means that each of us is feeling, I think, you need. very isolated. That distance is naturally going to change kind of the dynamic because you don't have that same proximity and the ease or access to this other person. It requires more of an investment. And if you're not willing to keep that up, you have to be willing to see that friendship fizzle out a little bit, not be what it once was or kind of hope that they return. And it's one of those magical moments where it's kind of right back to normal. So I think that's like the first|||你知道的，其中一个在尼泊尔，每个人都做出了对自己最好的决定。他们继续自己的生活。这意味着我们每个人都感到，我认为，你需要。非常孤立。这种距离自然会改变某种动态，因为你不再拥有那种亲密感，也没有那种与另一个人相处的便利或接触途径。这需要更多的投入。如果你不愿意维持下去，你就必须愿意看到那段友谊慢慢淡去，不再是昔日的模样，或者寄希望于他们归来。这是一个神奇的时刻，一切似乎又恢复了正常。所以我想这是第一个
big change I've seen in my personal life. The second factor has to do not just with specific friendships, but an entire way of socializing. The older we get, I think we lose some of our interest in the ways we used to hang out with our friends when we were 18 or 19 or even 20, particularly to do with the drinking culture. I know for me personally that when I was at uni, it was like binge drinking central. Like that was part of how we socialize. That was part of how we spent our, you know, Thursday, Friday, Saturday nights. It is this thing in psychology called bad behavior bonding where we sometimes find ourselves really attracted and attached to people who are on an equally chaotic and self-destructive path or in that same place as us in that
big change I've seen in my personal life. The second factor has to do not just with specific friendships, but an entire way of socializing. The older we get, I think we lose some of our interest in the ways we used to hang out with our friends when we were 18 or 19 or even 20, particularly to do with the drinking culture. I know for me personally that when I was at uni, it was like binge drinking central. Like that was part of how we socialize. That was part of how we spent our, you know, Thursday, Friday, Saturday nights. It is this thing in psychology called bad behavior bonding where we sometimes find ourselves really attracted and attached to people who are on an equally chaotic and self-destructive path or in that same place as us in that|||我在个人生活中看到的重大改变。第二个因素不仅与特定的友谊有关，还与整个社交方式有关。随着年龄的增长，我认为我们对 18、19 甚至 20 岁时与朋友聚会的方式失去了一些兴趣，特别是与饮酒文化有关的方式。我个人知道，当我上大学时，那里就像是酗酒中心。这就像是我们社交方式的一部分。那是我们度过周四、周五、周六夜晚的方式的一部分。心理学上有一个概念叫“不良行为凝聚”（bad behavior bonding），即有时我们会发现自己被那些处于同样混乱和自我毁灭道路上，或者在那个时刻处于与我们相同境地的人深深吸引和依恋。
moment and then we enable each other. But when one person decides it's kind of time to outgrow that, that they've matured past that kind of chapter, it comes at the cost of the friends they made through those behaviours. I think 18-year-old Gemma would be shocked to hear that, you know, I don't go clubbing really anymore. I don't really want to be up to 2am on a weeknight. I want to be in bed. I want to be watching Seinfeld. My threshold for social interaction, and I think most of the people's threshold for social interaction has lowered significantly as I've entered like my mid-20s. Some of that is obviously environmental, but also some of it is just psychological and personal. Like that's not what I'm really interested in anymore.
moment and then we enable each other. But when one person decides it's kind of time to outgrow that, that they've matured past that kind of chapter, it comes at the cost of the friends they made through those behaviours. I think 18-year-old Gemma would be shocked to hear that, you5 know, I don't go clubbing really anymore. I don't really want to be up to 2am on a weeknight. I want to be in bed. I want to be watching Seinfeld. My threshold for social interaction, and I think most of the people's threshold for social interaction has lowered significantly as I've entered like my mid-20s. Some of that is obviously environmental, but also some of it is just psychological and personal. Like that's not what I'm really interested in anymore.|||然后我们互相纵容。但当一个人决定是时候摆脱这一切、在心理上超越了那个章节时，代价就是失去通过这些行为结交的朋友。我想 18 岁的 Gemma 听到这个消息一定会大吃一惊，你知道的，我基本上不再去夜店了。我真的不想在工作日的晚上熬到凌晨 2 点。我想躺在床上。我想看《宋飞正传》。随着我进入二十岁中期，我对社交互动的门槛，以及我认为大多数人社交互动的门槛，已经显著降低了。其中一部分显然是环境使然，但也有一些纯粹是心理和个人原因。就像那已经不是我真正感兴趣的东西了。
And then there's the other factor of the fact that I have met someone that I have a partner now. When we enter into a relationship, the center of our social universe, our emotional universe or solar system, it shifts away from our friendships and towards our partner. And if you're not careful, you kind of fall out of orbit with those around you. You know, you want to spend as much time as possible with this person that you're falling in love with. You want to see them all the time. You want to invite them to everything that you're doing. That can sometimes come at the expense of those platonic relationships that you've maintained for much longer than you've known this person. So I think it's these like two to three parallel changes that have left me feeling pretty
And then there's the other factor of the fact that I have met someone that I have a partner now. When we enter into a relationship, the center of our social universe, our emotional universe or solar system, it shifts away from our friendships and towards our partner. And if you're not careful, you kind of fall out of orbit with those around you. You know, you want to spend as much time as possible with this person that you're falling in love with. You want to see them all the time. You want to invite them to everything that you're doing. That can sometimes come at the expense of those platonic relationships that you've maintained for much longer than you've known this person. So I think it's these like two to three parallel changes that have left me feeling pretty|||还有另一个因素，那就是我遇到了某人，我现在有伴侣了。当我们进入一段恋爱关系时，我们的社交宇宙、我们的情感宇宙或太阳系统的中心会从我们的友谊转移到我们的伴侣身上。如果你不小心，你就会脱离周围人的轨道。你知道的，你想花尽可能多的时间和你爱上的人在一起。你想无时无刻见到他们。你想邀请他们参加你正在做的每一件事。这有时会以牺牲那些你维持的时间远比认识这个人还要长的柏拉图式关系为代价。所以我想正是这两到三个平行的改变让我感到相当
isolated, perhaps feeling like I haven't adapted as quickly to these situations as I could have. However, I also recognize that in our 20s, we are riding what I like to call the friendship roller coaster. The friendship roller coaster is this phenomenon I've noticed whereby we can feel incredibly happy and fulfilled by our friendships, almost overwhelmed with love, you know, one day. And then three days later, you can end up in this total thought spiral about how we have no one, how we're totally alone, how no one wants to spend time with us, as if three days earlier you hadn't been having the best time. You hadn't been feeling totally validated. That is the friendship rollercoaster of our 20s.
isolated, perhaps feeling like I haven't adapted as quickly to these situations as I could have. However, I also recognize that in our 20s, we are riding what I like to call the friendship roller coaster. The friendship roller coaster is this phenomenon I've noticed whereby we can feel incredibly happy and fulfilled by our friendships, almost overwhelmed with love, you know, one day. And then three days later, you can end up in this total thought spiral about how we have no one, how we're totally alone, how no one wants to spend time with us, as if three days earlier you hadn't been having the best time. You hadn't been feeling totally validated. That is the friendship rollercoaster of our 20s.|||孤立，也许觉得自己对这些情况的适应速度不够快。然而，我也认识到，在我们的二十岁，我们正在乘坐我称之为友谊过山车的交通工具。友谊过山车是我注意到的这样一种现象：有一天，我们会对我们的友谊感到无比快乐和充实，几乎被爱淹没。然后三天后，你最终会陷入这样一种疯狂的胡思乱想中：我们一无所有，我们孤立无援，没有人想和我们在一起，就好像三天前你没有过得最开心一样。你没有感到完全被认可。这就是我们二十岁的友谊过山车。
there are a lot of really high highs and a lot of really low lows. And normally at those low points, nothing really has changed except our mental state. And it goes to show how so much of our experience of feeling isolated or lonely is entirely subjective. And it's based on what I think is a very instinctual inherent fear of loneliness that is not always based on the truth. it is a false alarm. That is why we are so fearful of our friendships changing, because underneath that fear is a much more primal fear of being alone. And so we become really hypervigilant to any cues, small suggestions that, you know, point to the fact that our relationships are weakening, that people are becoming more distant. Sometimes that is true. As sad as it is,
there are a lot of really high highs and a lot of really low lows. And normally at those low points, nothing really has changed except our mental state. And it goes to show how so much of our experience of feeling isolated or lonely is entirely subjective. And it's based on what I think is a very instinctual inherent fear of loneliness that is not always based on the truth. it is a false alarm. That is why we are so fearful of our friendships changing, because underneath that fear is a much more primal fear of being alone. And so we become really hypervigilant to any cues, small suggestions that, you5 know, point to the fact that our relationships are weakening, that people are becoming more distant. Sometimes that is true. As sad as it is,|||有很多非常高的高潮和非常低的低谷。通常在那些低谷期，除了我们的精神状态外，没有什么真正的改变。这表明我们感到孤立或孤独的经历在很大程度上完全是主观的。它基于我认为的一种非常本能的对孤独的内在恐惧，而这种恐惧并不总是基于事实。这是一个虚假警报。这就是为什么我们如此害怕友谊发生改变，因为在这种恐惧的背后，是一种更原始的对孤独的恐惧。因此，我们对任何暗示我们关系正在减弱、人们变得疏远的线索和微小暗示变得高度警惕。有时这是真的。尽管令人难过，
is we are naturally going to lose friends. It is unavoidable. And I want to talk about why we see that so often in our 20s in particular. This decade is a period of transition for all of us. Career transition, mental transition, emotional transition, even physical transition as we spoken about as we kind of move, we scatter, we pursue different paths. Everyone is kind of on their own, you know, I know it sounds cheesy, but their own journey in that moment. We are all trying equally as hard as everyone else to just figure out what we want from life and how we can actually do those things. It's interesting because I think although we are all the same age, we are all almost
is we are naturally going to lose friends. It is unavoidable. And I want to talk about why we see that so often in our 20s in particular. This decade is a period of transition for all of us. Career transition, mental transition, emotional transition, even physical transition as we spoken about as we kind of move, we scatter, we pursue different paths. Everyone is kind of on their own, you know, I know it sounds cheesy, but their own journey in that moment. We are all trying equally as hard as everyone else to just figure out what we want from life and how we can actually do those things. It's interesting because I think although we are all the same age, we are all almost|||那就是我们自然会失去朋友。这是不可避免的。我想谈谈为什么我们在二十岁时尤其经常看到这种现象。这十年对我们所有人来说都是一个过渡期。职业过渡、心理过渡、情感过渡，甚至正如我们所讨论的身体过渡，因为我们搬迁、我们四散、我们追求不同的道路。每个人都走在自己的路上，你知道，我知道这听起来很老套，但在那一刻，他们有自己的旅程。我们都在像其他人一样努力弄清楚我们对生活的期望以及我们如何才能真正做到这些事情。很有趣，因为我认为虽然我们年龄都一样，但我们几乎都处于
at like different life points. We've all hit different milestones. Some of us are still living at home. Some of us have moved in with like partners. We're living abroad. Some of us are still at use. we are all at these very different stages, whereas for the first 18 years of our lives, if someone was our age, we could assume that they were doing a lot of the same things as we were.
at like different life points. We've all hit different milestones. Some of us are still living at home. Some of us have moved in with like partners. We're living abroad. Some of us are still at use. we are all at these very different stages, whereas for the first 18 years of our lives, if someone was our age, we could assume that they were doing a lot of the same things as we were.|||不同的生活节点。我们都达到了不同的里程碑。我们中的一些人仍然住在家里。我们中的一些人已经和伴侣同居了。我们住在国外。我们中的一些人还在使用。我们都处于这些截然不同的阶段，而在我们生命的前 18 年里，如果有人和我们同龄，我们可以假设他们在做很多和我们一样的事情。
We were kind of living parallel lives because of the structures of childhood and adolescence. But in our 20s, that all splinters. It's kind of like a life path explosion. It's at this point of, I don't want to say, you know, upheaval, but like significantly. growth and impact, that we see the relationships around us change as well, and they will continue to do so for the remainder of our 20s and the remainder of our lives. One of the biggest moments that I think we encounter this is following university or high school. When we are at uni, we spend so much time together. There is just endless opportunities to be around your friends, opportunities to laugh, to have fun,
We were kind of living parallel lives because of the structures of childhood and adolescence. But in our 20s, that all splinters. It's kind of like a life path explosion. It's at this point of, I don't want to say, you know, upheaval, but like significantly. growth and impact, that we see the relationships around us change as well, and they will continue to do so for the remainder of our 20s and the remainder of our lives. One of the biggest moments that I think we encounter this is following university or high school. When we are at uni, we spend so much time together. There is just endless opportunities to be around your friends, opportunities to laugh, to have fun,|||由于童年和青春期的结构，我们过着平行生活。但在我们二十岁时，这一切都支离破碎了。这有点像人生道路的爆发。正是在这个我不想说你知道的剧变，而是显著成长和影响的时刻，我们看到周围的关系也在发生变化，并且在我们的二十岁剩下的时间和我们余生中，它们将继续发生变化。我认为我们遇到这种情况最大的时刻之一是在大学或高中之后。当我们在大学时，我们花很多时间在一起。有无穷无尽的机会和你的朋友在一起，有机会大笑，玩得开心，
and we are having this very shared experience. We're working towards the same goal to, you know, graduate at the end of all this. And our friendships at that point are really, really convenient. You are living in the same place, possibly the same town, even sometimes the same building. You're going to the library every day. You are eating together every day, seeing each other as much as you can. And when we no longer have, A, those shared experiences or B, the shared environment, we slowly lose that closeness. And to understand this, we really need to look at the psychological
and we are having this very shared experience. We're working towards the same goal to, you5 know, graduate at the end of all this. And our friendships at that point are really, really convenient. You are living in the same place, possibly the same town, even sometimes the same building. You're going to the library every day. You are eating together every day, seeing each other as much as you can. And when we no longer have, A, those shared experiences or B, the shared environment, we slowly lose that closeness. And to understand this, we really need to look at the psychological|||我们有着这种高度共享的经历。我们朝着同一个目标努力，你知道，在这一切结束时毕业。那时的友谊真的非常非常方便。你们住在同一个地方，可能是同一个城镇，有时甚至是同一栋楼。你每天去图书馆。你们每天一起吃饭，尽可能多地见面。当我们不再拥有 A，那些共同的经历，或者 B，共同的环境时，我们慢慢失去了这种亲密感。要理解这一点，我们真的需要看看心理学
principles underlying friendship. These researchers back in the 90s, they proposed that there are four key ingredients or factors that can basically predict whether you and someone else will become friends and also whether you'll be able to maintain that friendship. And these like ingredients are proximity, similarity, familiarity and reciprocity. So proximity basically just means physical closeness. How easy is it for you to see this person regularly? They did a study on this at university dorm rooms and they found that how close people's rooms were to each other actually predicted the likelihood of them becoming friends. A lot of our friendships, basically come down to the ease of contact and the frequency of contact. Secondly, we have similarity.
principles underlying friendship. These researchers back in the 90s, they proposed that there are four key ingredients or factors that can basically predict whether you and someone else will become friends and also whether you'll be able to maintain that friendship. And these like ingredients are proximity, similarity, familiarity and reciprocity. So proximity basically just means physical closeness. How easy is it for you to see this person regularly? They did a study on this at university dorm rooms and they found that how close people's rooms were to each other actually predicted the likelihood of them becoming friends. A lot of our friendships, basically come down to the ease of contact and the frequency of contact. Secondly, we have similarity.|||友谊背后的原则。上世纪 90 年代的这些研究人员提出，有四个关键成分或因素基本上可以预测你是否会与某人成为朋友，以及你是否能够维持这种友谊。这些成分包括邻近性（proximity）、相似性（similarity）、熟悉度（familiarity）和互惠性（reciprocity）。因此，邻近性基本上意味着身体上的接近。你定期见到这个人的难易程度如何？他们在大学宿舍里对此进行了研究，发现人们的房间彼此有多近实际上预示了他们成为朋友的可能性。我们的许多友谊基本上归结为接触的便利性和接触的频率。其次，我们有相似性。
We're obviously going to like someone more if they share the same interests, hobbies, lifestyle beliefs as us. But this also includes similarity in terms of current and past life experiences or sharing a similar environment. Then we have familiarity that refers to not just how long we've known someone, how close we are with them, but also the depth of the connection. You know, sometimes we think that the people who have known us the longest know us the best. That is not always the case. Sometimes we meet people and there is just this intense, intense spark, this intense platonic chemistry such that we automatically immediately feel like we have known them our whole lives. Familiarity is basically just close knowledge of another person.
We're obviously going to like someone more if they share the same interests, hobbies, lifestyle beliefs as us. But this also includes similarity in terms of current and past life experiences or sharing a similar environment. Then we have familiarity that refers to not just how long we've known someone, how close we are with them, but also the depth of the connection. You5 know, sometimes we think that the people who have known us the longest know us the best. That is not always the case. Sometimes we meet people and there is just this intense, intense spark, this intense platonic chemistry such that we automatically immediately feel like we have known them our whole lives. Familiarity is basically just close knowledge of another person.|||如果某人与我们有着相同的兴趣、爱好、生活方式信念，我们显然会更喜欢他们。但这还包括当前和过去生活经历方面的相似性，或者共享类似的环境。然后我们有熟悉度，它不仅指我们认识某多久、我们和他们有多亲密，还指连接的深度。你知道，有时我们认为认识我们最久的人最了解我们。事实并非总是如此。有时我们遇到某人，会有一种强烈、强烈的火花，这种强烈的柏拉图式化学反应，让我们自动立即觉得我们一生都在认识他们。熟悉度基本上只是对另一个人的密切了解。
And finally we have reciprocity, which is knowing that what you give someone in terms of your love, in terms of your energy, in terms of your time is going to be returned, is going to be reciprocated. So those are the most important factors. When we talk about our friendships changing in our 20s, nine out of ten times, I would say that change normally comes down to a shift in one of these four conditions. For example, when people move away or they get really busy, they start full-time work, we lose that proximity. It makes it harder to see them. When we lose those shared experiences like no longer being at university together, we have less to talk about. When we lose that familiarity, we feel like this
And finally we have reciprocity, which is knowing that what you give someone in terms of your love, in terms of your energy, in terms of your time is going to be returned, is going to be reciprocated. So those are the most important factors. When we talk about our friendships changing in our 20s, nine out of ten times, I would say that change normally comes down to a shift in one of these four conditions. For example, when people move away or they get really busy, they start full-time work, we lose that proximity. It makes it harder to see them. When we lose those shared experiences like no longer being at university together, we have less to talk about. When we lose that familiarity, we feel like this|||最后是互惠性，即知道你给予别人的爱、精力、时间会得到回报，会得到互惠。这些是最重要的因素。当我们谈论我们在二十岁的友谊发生改变时，十有八九，我会说这种改变通常归结为这四个条件之一的变化。例如，当人们搬走或变得非常忙碌，开始全职工作时，我们就失去了这种邻近性。这使得见他们变得更加困难。当我们失去那些共同的经历，比如不再一起上大学时，我们的话题就变少了。当我们失去那种熟悉度时，我们觉得这个
person no longer knows us. And when we begin to see a friendship as one-sided without that reciprocity we were speaking about, this is when it makes us. question how much this person really wants us to be in their life. What I often say is that friendships can survive a reduction or a change in one of these conditions, but not to. So, for example, it's totally fine if your friend gets really busy at work and can only see you once a fortnight, once a month, as long as you maintain that similarity, familiarity, reciprocity. You make time when you have time and you talk about things that are interesting and you want to see them. But if suddenly you no longer have those shared stories, beliefs, values, interests, and then you also don't see them
person no longer knows us. And when we begin to see a friendship as one-sided without that reciprocity we were speaking about, this is when it makes us. question how much this person really wants us to be in their life. What I often say is that friendships can survive a reduction or a change in one of these conditions, but not to. So, for example, it's totally fine if your friend gets really busy at work and can only see you once a fortnight, once a month, as long as you maintain that similarity, familiarity, reciprocity. You make time when you have time and you talk about things that are interesting and you want to see them. But if suddenly you no longer have those shared stories, beliefs, values, interests, and then you also don't see them|||人不再了解我们。当我们开始把一段友谊看作是单方面的，而没有我们所说的这种互惠性时，这正是让我们产生疑问的时候。质疑这个人到底有多希望我们在他/她的生命中。我经常说的是，友谊可以经受住其中一个条件的减少或改变，但不能经受两个。因此，例如，如果你的朋友工作非常忙，两周或一个月只能见你一次，只要你保持那种相似性、熟悉度、互惠性，那就完全没问题。有时间的时候腾出时间，谈论有趣的事情，你想见他们。但如果突然之间你不再拥有那些共同的故事、信念、价值观、利益，然后你也不再见他们
regularly, that is when the friendship starts to crumble. Or if the friend is not reciprocating your excitement or your investment in seeing them, again, we really begin to question the value of the friendship or how much longer it can last. I want to stress this again. I know that that feels really painful, but it's not abnormal. You are not the only one who was either going through these changes themselves, struggling to connect with people you once loved, or watching someone else feel the same way about your friendship. Watching the people around you suddenly almost disappear. Friendships change because people change and sometimes they just don't change in the same direction. That is not a crime. It is.
regularly, that is when the friendship starts to crumble. Or if the friend is not reciprocating your excitement or your investment in seeing them, again, we really begin to question the value of the friendship or how much longer it can last. I want to stress this again. I know that that feels really painful, but it's not abnormal. You are not the only one who was either going through these changes themselves, struggling to connect with people you once loved, or watching someone else feel the same way about your friendship. Watching the people around you suddenly almost disappear. Friendships change because people change and sometimes they just don't change in the same direction. That is not a crime. It is.|||定期见面，友谊就开始崩溃了。或者，如果朋友没有对你见他们的兴奋或投入做出回应，我们再次真正开始质疑友谊的价值或它还能持续多久。我想再次强调这一点。我知道这感觉真的很痛苦，但这并非不正常。你不是唯一一个经历这些变化的人，在与曾经爱过的人建立联系时苦苦挣扎，或者看着别人对你的友谊也有同样的感受。看着周围的人突然几乎消失了。友谊会改变，因为人会变，有时他们只是没有朝着同一个方向改变。这不是犯罪。它是。
not because there is something wrong with you or something wrong with them. I think the worst thing we can do in response to that is actually act from a place of anger or rejection because you're not actually angry at them. You're just hurt. You're just scared of losing them. You're just scared of change. And your sadness and your panic is in itself and indicated that you love them deeply. So I think when we are in those moments where we are really fearful that we're losing
not because there is something wrong with you or something wrong with them. I think the worst thing we can do in response to that is actually act from a place of anger or rejection because you're not actually angry at them. You're just hurt. You're just scared of losing them. You're just scared of change. And your sadness and your panic is in itself and indicated that you love them deeply. So I think when we are in those moments where we are really fearful that we're losing|||并不是因为你有什么问题或者他们有什么问题。我认为面对这种情况，我们能做的最糟糕的事情其实是出于愤怒或拒绝的心态采取行动，因为你其实并不是在生他们的气。你只是受伤了。你只是害怕失去他们。你只是害怕改变。你的悲伤和恐慌本身就表明你深深地爱着他们。所以我想当我们处于那些真正害怕失去的时刻时
people, feeling like we should push them away, or, you know, sometimes find a replacement. We do just need to pause and approach this very rationally. This is all about a transition. It's all about a journey. And where you are at now with your friends, like we said, it is the friendship roller coaster. It may not be where you end up. There are other factors as well that I think also alter our friendships irreversibly. and that includes really significant events like a big breach of trust, a betrayal, misunderstandings. I think these things differ from what we were talking about before. And when we encounter those things, there are four kind of friendship breakups that we most often see.
people, feeling like we should push them away, or, you5 know, sometimes find a replacement. We do just need to pause and approach this very rationally. This is all about a transition. It's all about a journey. And where you are at now with your friends, like we said, it is the friendship roller coaster. It may not be where you end up. There are other factors as well that I think also alter our friendships irreversibly. and that includes really significant events like a big breach of trust, a betrayal, misunderstandings. I think these things differ from what we were talking before. And when we encounter those things, there are four kind of friendship breakups that we most often see.|||人，觉得我们应该把他们推开，或者，你知道，有时找一个替代品。我们确实需要停下来，非常理性地对待这件事。这一切都是关于过渡。这一切都是关于一段旅程。正如我们所说，你现在和朋友们处境如何，这就是友谊过山车。这可能不是你的最终归宿。还有其他因素，我认为这些因素也会不可逆转地改变我们的友谊。这包括非常重大的事件，比如严重的信任危机、背叛、误解。我认为这些事情与我们之前谈论的不同。当我们遇到这些事情时，我们最常看到四种类型的友谊破裂。
These are the friendship fizzle, the replacement, the one-sided severance, and the breakup, where really drastic measures are required. So I would say if we have a look at our friendships, the mutual and, you know, friendships from the past, the mutual fizzle is most common. There are some people we are not meant to be around our entire lives. We are only meant to be with them for a season. Before it is, you know, time for us to move on. Maybe this person just no longer feels your cup in the same way.
These are the friendship fizzle, the replacement, the one-sided severance, and the breakup, where really drastic measures are required. So I would say if we have a look at our friendships, the mutual and, you5 know, friendships from the past, the mutual fizzle is most common. There are some people we are not meant to be around our entire lives. We are only meant to be with them for a season. Before it is, you5 know, time for us to move on. Maybe this person just no longer feels your cup in the same way.|||这些是友谊的逐渐淡出、替代、单方面的断交，以及需要采取真正极端措施的分手。所以我想说，如果我们看看我们的友谊，相互的，你知道，过去的友谊，相互的淡出是最常见的。有些人我们注定不能一生都在一起。我们注定只能陪他们度过一段时间。在你知道是时候继续前进之前。也许这个人不再以同样的方式填满你的杯子了。
You were friends at work. Now you no longer have that shared topic to discuss. they were your exes friends. The key word though here is mutual. We both kind of understand that we aren't as close as we once were. The context around us has changed and perhaps it's time to actually just let the other person go. Stop trying to reschedule the plans. Just let it fizzle. Then we have the replacement. This one really hurts. It hurts so much. Sometimes we have this really intense relationship with someone. They're our best friend. We do everything together and then slowly they start mentioning some other person more and more. They're spending more time with them.
You were friends at work. Now you no longer have that shared topic to discuss. they were your exes friends. The key word though here is mutual. We both kind of understand that we aren't as close as we once were. The context around us has changed and perhaps it's time to actually just let the other person go. Stop trying to reschedule the plans. Just let it fizzle. Then we have the replacement. This one really hurts. It hurts so much. Sometimes we have this really intense relationship with someone. They're our best friend. We do everything together and then slowly they start mentioning some other person more and more. They're spending more time with them.|||你们曾是工作上的朋友。现在你们不再有共同的话题可谈了。他们是你前任的朋友。不过这里的关键词是“相互的”。我们都有些明白，我们不像以前那么亲密了。我们周围的背景已经改变，也许是时候真正放手让对方离开了。不要再试图重新安排计划了。就让它自然淡去吧。然后我们有替代。这个真的很痛。太痛了。有时我们和某人有这种非常强烈关系。他们是我们最好的朋友。我们一起做所有事情，然后慢慢地他们开始越来越多地提到其他人。他们花更多时间陪他们。
We feel shut out or replaced. Or perhaps, as we were talking about before, they meet someone. They meet a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a partner. Even though we know that we are not entitled to all of their time, a lot of this comes from a very, I think, justified place of jealous. jealousy. And it's a jealousy we typically think it's reserved for romantic relationships. But when you love someone as deeply as you love this person, another individual's kind of entrance into your relationship or like the equation can feel like a real threat. And it's these friendships, I think, those very, very, very close friendships that keep us quite grounded that actually form a huge part of our identity and how we see ourselves. So when one person,
We feel shut out or replaced. Or perhaps, as we were talking about before, they meet someone. They meet a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a partner. Even though we know that we are not entitled to all of their time, a lot of this comes from a very, I think, justified place of jealous. jealousy. And it's a jealousy we typically think it's reserved for romantic relationships. But when you love someone as deeply as you love this person, another individual's kind of entrance into your relationship or like the equation can feel like a real threat. And it's these friendships, I think, those very, very, very close friendships that keep us quite grounded that actually form a huge part of our identity and how we see ourselves. So when one person,|||我们感到被排挤或被取代。或者也许正如我们之前所说，他们遇到了某人。他们遇到了男朋友、女朋友或伴侣。尽管我们知道我们无权占用他们的全部时间，但其中很大一部分来自于一个非常合理的嫉妒之地。嫉妒。这是一种我们通常认为专属于恋爱关系的嫉妒。但当你像爱这个人一样深深地爱着某人时，另一个人进入你们的关系或像公式一样的存在会让人感到真正的威胁。我认为正是这些友谊，那些非常非常非常亲密的友谊让我们保持脚踏实地，实际上构成了我们身份和我们如何看待自己的很大一部分。所以当一个人，
seemingly moves on or stops investing as much or starts investing more in someone else, it can quite honestly leave us feeling really lost, maybe feel like we should be sharing our time around as well. There's also a saying about these intense relationships that really applies here. The flame that burns twice as bright burns out quicker. I see this all the time with those really high intensity friendships. You're kind of like addicted to them. You put a lot of pressure on them more than other friendships, you have this really high expectation, this high level of time that you spend with each other and a lot of demands for the other person that I think can rarely be sustained without the occasional break or some very solid boundaries. And I don't think that
seemingly moves on or stops investing as much or starts investing more in someone else, it can quite honestly leave us feeling really lost, maybe feel like we should be sharing our time around as well. There's also a saying about these intense relationships that really applies here. The flame that burns twice as bright burns out quicker. I see this all the time with those really high intensity friendships. You're kind of like addicted to them. You put a lot of pressure on them more than other friendships, you have this really high expectation, this high level of time that you spend with each other and a lot of demands for the other person that I think can rarely be sustained without the occasional break or some very solid boundaries. And I don't think that|||表面上向前看，或者停止投入那么多，或者开始在其他人身上投入更多，老实说，这会让我们感到非常迷失，也许觉得我们也应该把时间分给其他人。关于这些激烈的关系，也有一句非常适用于此的俗语。燃烧得加倍耀眼的光芒，熄灭得也更快。我在那些高强度的友谊中经常看到这种情况。你有点像对它们上瘾。你对他们施加了比其他友谊更多的压力，你对他们抱有很高的期望，你们彼此相处的时间很长，对对方有很多要求，我认为如果没有偶尔的休息或一些非常坚实的界限，这种关系很难维持下去。我不认为
those relationships, those really intense relationships, can survive very long without one person in that kind of dynamic choosing to make a change, which is why, I think not only do they hurt a lot, but we also see them ending quite frequently. And then we have this one-sided severance where without reason, someone suddenly detaches, doesn't want to talk to you, doesn't want to communicate with you, doesn't really offer you any kind of explanation. That is just, I can understand how devastating that is. I've had that happen to me before. Sometimes people have their reason. they don't want to share them with you, that's fine.
those relationships, those really intense relationships, can survive very long without one person in that kind of dynamic choosing to make a change, which is why, I think not only do they hurt a lot, but we also see them ending quite frequently. And then we have this one-sided severance where without reason, someone suddenly detaches, doesn't want to talk to you, doesn't want to communicate with you, doesn't really offer you any kind of explanation. That is just, I can understand how devastating that is. I've had that happen to me before. Sometimes people have their reason. they don't want to share them with you, that's fine.|||这些关系，那些非常激烈的关系，如果在这种动态中没有人选择做出改变，是无法存活很长时间的，这就是为什么我认为它们不仅会带来巨大的伤害，而且我们还看到它们相当频繁地结束。然后我们有这种单方面的断交，在没有理由的情况下，某人突然疏离，不想跟你说话，不想跟你沟通，不给你任何形式的解释。那真是，我能理解这有多毁灭性。我以前也经历过这种情况。有时人们有他们的理由。他们不想和你分享，那也没关系。
But you're kind of having to go through a friendship breakup all on your own without the closure. We have to go searching for the answers ourselves. I think when a true friendship breakup actually occurs, we kind of both understand why. We know what happened. We know our role in it. We know what we need to take accountability for. But when we have these one-sided severances, you really are kind of left in the dark. You're left looking for your own answers.
But you're kind of having to go through a friendship breakup all on your own without the closure. We have to go searching for the answers ourselves. I think when a true friendship breakup actually occurs, we kind of both understand why. We know what happened. We know our role in it. We know what we need to take accountability for. But when we have these one-sided severances, you really are kind of left in the dark. You're left looking for your own answers.|||但你不得不在没有得到结局的情况下独自经历友谊的分手。我们必须自己去寻找答案。我认为当真正的友谊破裂发生时，我们两个人都大概明白为什么。我们知道发生了什么。我们知道我们在其中的角色。我们知道我们需要承担什么责任。但当我们经历这些单方面的断交时，你真的被蒙在鼓里。你只能自己去寻找答案。
I really do believe that friendship breakups hurt so much more than romantic breakups because we never expect them. Friendships always feel so permanent. And as we get older, we quickly realize that they're not. It is okay to grieve what was to think about them, to want to reach out. But it's also okay to recognize that just like the end of a romantic relationship, this might have been for the best. Sometimes not only do we grow apart, but we begin to kind of realize and recognize how this person has caused friction in our lives, may not have respected our boundaries, or maybe there was some event where suddenly you saw them in a new light and you're just
I really do believe that friendship breakups hurt so much more than romantic breakups because we never expect them. Friendships always feel so permanent. And as we get older, we quickly realize that they're not. It is okay to grieve what was to think about them, to want to reach out. But it's also okay to recognize that just like the end of a romantic relationship, this might have been for the best. Sometimes not only do we grow apart, but we begin to kind of realize and recognize how this person has caused friction in our lives, may not have respected our boundaries, or maybe there was some event where suddenly you saw them in a new light and you're just|||我真的相信友谊的分手比恋爱的分手要痛苦得多，因为我们从未预料到它们会发生。友谊总是显得那么持久。随着年龄的增长，我们很快意识到并非如此。为过去的事情感到悲伤、去想念他们、想要去联系是完全可以的。但认识到就像恋爱关系的结束一样，这可能是最好的结果，也是可以接受的。有时我们不仅渐行渐远，而且开始意识到并认识到这个人是如何在我们的生活中造成摩擦的，可能没有尊重我们的边界，或者也许发生了某件事，突然之间你以一种新的眼光看待他们，而你只是
shocked that this is actually who they are and you've never seen that before. I actually had someone tell me the other day about a friendship breakup they had with their best friend of eight years. And they went on vacation together and throughout this trip, this person slowly realized that her and her friend could not be friends anymore, that when she returned, it would have to be over. Her friend was cruel, would yell at her, would ignore her when other people were around, wasn't willing to compromise. That is not a relationship. we should prioritize.
shocked that this is actually who they are and you've never seen that before. I actually had someone tell me the other day about a friendship breakup they had with their best friend of eight years. And they went on vacation together and throughout this trip, this person slowly realized that her and her friend could not be friends anymore, that when she returned, it would have to be over. Her friend was cruel, would yell at her, would ignore her when other people were around, wasn't willing to compromise. That is not a relationship. we should prioritize.|||震惊于这竟然就是他们的真实面目，而你以前从未见过。其实前几天有人跟我说起他们和八年挚友分手的事。他们一起去度假，在整个旅行过程中，这个人慢慢意识到她和她的朋友再也不能做朋友了，等她回来时，这一切都得结束了。她的朋友很残忍，会对她大喊大叫，当有其他人在场时会忽视她，不愿妥协。这不是我们应该优先考虑的关系。
And sometimes we don't see those parts of someone until we see them in a new situation, like a wedding, like an engagement, like a baby is coming, or one of you is experiencing like a lot of really great success and the other person is jealous. I guess in those situations, it's better to kind of feel lonely
And sometimes we don't see those parts of someone until we see them in a new situation, like a wedding, like an engagement, like a baby is coming, or one of you is experiencing like a lot of really great success and the other person is jealous. I guess in those situations, it's better to kind of feel lonely|||有时我们直到在新的情况下看到某个人的那些部分时才看到它们，比如婚礼、订婚、有宝宝要出生，或者你们其中一方经历了很多巨大的成功而另一个人嫉妒。我想在这种情况下，感觉孤独总比
than to be around someone or trust someone who obviously doesn't have your best intentions at heart. And I guess that's one of my main premises or arguments here. Not all friendships are meant to last for a good reason. And our fear of loneliness should not keep us in relationships that do not nurture and build us up and make us better people. We should not sacrifice our boundaries or our needs for the sake of company. You can find company anywhere.
than to be around someone or trust someone who obviously doesn't have your best intentions at heart. And I guess that's one of my main premises or arguments here. Not all friendships are meant to last for a good reason. And our fear of loneliness should not keep us in relationships that do not nurture and build us up and make us better people. We should not sacrifice our boundaries or our needs for the sake of company. You can find company anywhere.|||总比和那些显然对你没有安好心的人在一起或信任他们要好。我想这也是我的主要前提或论点之一。并非所有的友谊都注定长久，这是有充分理由的。我们对孤独的恐惧不应该让我们留在那些不能滋养我们、建立我们并让我们成为更好的人的关系中。我们不应该为了陪伴而牺牲我们的边界或需求。你在任何地方都能找到陪伴。
You can go to the local coffee shop and have a chat with some nice lady in her 60s and there you go bingo-bang-go, you have a best friend. When we continue to pour attention and time and energy into these dead-end relationships, we lose out on a lot of other opportunities to meet people who might suit this chapter or season of your life better, even if it takes some time. The saying that I always come back to again and again and again. It is impossible to keep every single friend you've ever had, especially as you add new relationships, when your life circumstances change, or when you become aware of key differences
You can go to the local coffee shop and have a chat with some nice lady in her 60s and there you go bingo-bang-go, you have a best friend. When we continue to pour attention and time and energy into these dead-end relationships, we lose out on a lot of other opportunities to meet people who might suit this chapter or season of your life better, even if it takes some time. The saying that I always come back to again and again and again. It is impossible to keep every single friend you've ever had, especially as you add new relationships, when your life circumstances change, or when you become aware of key differences|||你可以去当地的咖啡店，和一位 60 岁左右的慈祥女士聊聊天，然后大功告成，你就拥有了一个最好的朋友。当我们继续把注意力、时间和精力投入到这些死胡同般的关系中时，我们就会失去很多其他机会去结识那些可能更适合你人生这个章节或季节的人，即使这需要一些时间。我一次又一次不断回想起的那句话。保留你曾经有过的每一个朋友是不可能的，特别是当你增加了新的关系、当你的人生环境发生改变、或者当你意识到关键差异时
in your values and characters. It does not make you a bad person to want to move on, but it also doesn't make you a bad person to grieve and still know that that was necessary. So what I really want to discuss next is how to manage your kind of changing friendship landscape. Whether it is you're seeing more of the fizzle or there has been a friendship breakup or people have moved, what are the do's and don'ts of evolving friendships in our 20s? So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
in your values and characters. It does not make you a bad person to want to move on, but it also doesn't make you a bad person to grieve and still know that that was necessary. So what I really want to discuss next is how to manage your kind of changing friendship landscape. Whether it is you're seeing more of the fizzle or there has been a friendship breakup or people have moved, what are the do's and don'ts of evolving friendships in our 20s? So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||在你的价值观和性格中。想要向前看并不意味着你是个坏人，但为之悲伤并仍然知道那是必要的，也不意味着你是个坏人。所以我接下来真正想讨论的是如何管理你那不断变化的友谊版图。无论是你看到越来越多的淡出，还是发生了友谊破裂，亦或是人们搬走了，在我们的二十岁，演变友谊的“做与不做”是什么？所有这些以及更多内容，就在这段短暂的休息之后。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and food. fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和食品健身专家等人进行交流，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油天生会引发炎症。我们错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Sent. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-P-Sent，在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选这一期，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的，包括最近一期马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈 80 年代瘾品的节目。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时都可以聊瘾品，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二期节目，所以我开始发现其中有一条主线。我们现在还有艾滋病的问题，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host,
对。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人，
and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过分卷入追逐之中，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着计分板，生活变成了赢与输。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层级的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct?
我希望你真正做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律之战，以证明真相。斯旺女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg a lesbian. Michael Marantini.
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯利。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
There are a few common misconceptions about friendships that I think make us feel particularly panicked when we notice things changing in our 20s. The first one that I think is perpetrated, especially during this decade, is that we need to have a massive group of friends in order to be happy. This personally drives me insane because I have never been someone who has had this one big jolly group of friends who do everything together. And I personally blame shows like friends and new girl for this idea that we need this one tight group of people. from ages like 10 to 60 or whatever, like for our entire adult life in order to be happy. Or this argument that we can't be equally fulfilled by one-on-one friendships. When we strip it down, what we really need friends for is trust, comfort, love and belonging. And it doesn't matter what form that comes in.
关于友谊，有一些常见的误解，我认为这会让我们在二十多岁时注意到事情发生变化时感到特别恐慌。我认为被宣扬的第一个误解，特别是在这个十年里，是我们为了快乐必须拥有一个庞大的朋友圈。这绝对把我逼疯了，因为我从来都不是那种拥有一个庞大、快乐、做什么都在一起的朋友群的人。我个人把《老友记》和《杰茜驾到》等节目归咎于这种想法，即我们需要从 10 岁到 60 岁左右或无论什么年龄，都有一个紧密团结的人群，也就是为了我们整个成年生活能够快乐。或者这种观点，即我们无法从一对一的友谊中获得同等的满足感。当我们剥丝抽茧时，我们真正需要朋友的原因是信任、安慰、爱和归属感。而这以什么形式出现并不重要。
It doesn't matter if it's a huge group situation or if it looks different to what we see others doing, you know, in social media or what we see other people doing online or in the movies and the TV shows that we watch. A lot of that is fiction. And I don't think that we should buy into this idea that just because you've never had a big group of girlfriends or a big group of friends that somehow you are lonelier than the rest. The second biggest misconception is that you should continue a friendship because you owe it to this. them, either due to the length of time that you've known each other, or maybe because they have a lot going on in their life. One therapist calls this a sense of emotional servitude, because it involves
这并不重要，不管是大型聚人群情况，还是它看起来与我们在社交媒体上看到的其他人所做的事情不同，或者我们在网上或其他人在我们观看的电影和电视剧中看到的事情不同。很多都是虚构的。而且我不认为我们应该相信这种观点，即仅仅因为你从来没有过一大群女朋友或一大群朋友，你就会比其他人更孤独。第二个最大的误解是，你应该继续一段友谊，因为你欠他们的，这要么是因为你们认识的时间长短，要么可能是因为他们生活中有许多事情。一位治疗师称之为情感奴役感，因为它涉及
putting effort towards a friendship as if you're paying off a debt or paying off, you know, or paying them this like energy this time without ever getting anything back for you. Like, you are doing the emotional labour for this other person. And I see this a lot with friends in, essentially, situation where one party is really going through something really difficult, but despite that, has no respect for the well-being of the other person, has no appreciation for the other person's boundaries, has no appreciation for what the other person needs. Sometimes that's understandable, right? If you're going through a really hard season in life, you're not always that aware of what other people are doing. Empathy is kind of not something that you can prioritize at that moment,
为了友谊付出努力，就像你在还清债务或付清钱，你知道的，或者付给他们这种能量、这种时间，而自己却从来没有得到任何回报。就像你在为另一个人做情感劳动一样。我经常在朋友身上看到这种情况，本质上是一种一方正经历非常困难的事情，但尽管如此，却不尊重另一个人的福祉，不感激另一个人的界限，不感激另一个人需要什么的情况。有时这是可以理解的，对吧？如果你正在经历生活中的一个非常艰难的时期，你并不总是那么清楚其他人正在做什么。同理心在那个时刻并不是你可以优先考虑的事情，
But that does not mean that you are not allowed to set boundaries with this person just because you're afraid of appearing disloyal or you're afraid of upsetting them, right? That relationship when it gets to that point is actually if you maintain it without setting up proper parameters or limits is going to do a lot more harm than good. It is going to end up hurting both of you. and we see that a lot with people that have also been friends with someone for a really long time and even though they just have nothing in common anymore even though this person may drain their energy may actually make them feel bad about themselves they stay because they don't want to be labeled
但这并不意味着你不能对这个人设定界限，仅仅因为你害怕显得不忠或者你害怕惹恼他们，对吧？当关系发展到那个地步时，如果你在没有建立适当参数或限制的情况下维持它，实际上会弊大于利。它最终会伤害你们两个人。我们在那些和某人做了很久朋友的人身上经常看到这一点，即使他们再也没有任何共同点，即使这个人可能会消耗他们的能量，甚至可能让他们对自我感觉不好，他们依然坚持，因为他们不想被打上
as someone who leaves and i think when you hold on too tight to people who don't want to maintain the relationship or who don't appreciate you you're basically carrying a dead weight that is holding you back from a new season of friendship and a new season of connection for you. The third misconception is that it's too late for you to make new friends that by our 20s, we should already know the people who will be in our wedding party or be our children's godparents or who will mourn at their funeral. I think that is absolutely incorrect. Research has shown that we replace half of our friends every seven years up until old age, which is to say that we are constantly in a state of pruning our friendships, letting go of certain friends, letting them drift,
一个离开的人的标签，而且我认为当你抓紧那些不想维系关系或不感激你的人不放时，你基本上是在背负一个沉重的包袱，它阻碍你走向新一季的友谊和新的连接。第三个误解是，你现在交新朋友已经太晚了，因为到了二十多岁，我们应该已经认识了那些将成为我们伴郎伴娘、或者我们孩子的教父教母、或者会在我们葬礼上哀悼的人。我认为这绝对是不对的。研究表明，直到老年，我们每七年就会更换一半的朋友，也就是说我们不断处于修剪友谊的状态中，放手某些朋友，任由他们疏远，
and then subsequently making new ones throughout life. I read an article that put it really, really well that you are not going to be the same person your entire life and you cannot expect other people to be the same version of themselves as well. You have changed, so much in the past 10 years, five years, even the last six months. So it makes sense that those around you, those relationships have also shifted with time. Yes, there might be certain friendships that have evolved to align with this new version of you and this new version of themselves. But it's sometimes just not feasible for you to keep up with every single person who has known you since you were a child, who is no nuisance you were a teenager.
并在随后的生活中不断结交新朋友。我读过一篇文章，把这一点阐述得非常好：你不会一辈子都是同一个人，你也不能期望其他人永远保持同一个版本的自己。在过去的 10 年、5 年甚至过去的 6 年里，你已经改变了太多。所以周围的人、那些关系随着时间推移也发生了转变，这是合乎情理的。是的，可能某些友谊已经进化，以适应这个新版本的你和他们自己的新版本。但有时，你要跟进每一个从小就认识你、甚至是十几岁时就认识你的人，这简直是行不通的。
There's just not enough time in the week. Like there genuinely just isn't enough time in the day to maintain connections with everybody. So you need to give yourself, I think, space to make new friendships that might fulfill you more without being scared that you will never find anybody. I kind of want to reiterate that.
一周的时间根本不够。就像一天中确实没有足够的时间来维持与每个人的联系。所以我觉得你需要给自己留出空间去建立新的友谊，这些友谊可能会给你带来更多满足感，而不用害怕你永远找不到任何人。我有点想重申这一点。
Do not hold on to these relationships just because you're scared that no one will fill their place or fill that social need in your life. I think that there are so many people that will just show up in your life one day by surprise and change everything. But you do need to leave space for them. And leaving space means the following. Don't adopt the philosophy that you already have all the friends you need. It may feel true, but you never know. You truly never know how much opening yourself up to that one extra person could really like change everything for you. Also say yes to things even when they scare you to invitations to activities to joining sports clubs to new hobbies. Take on the philosophy that
不要仅仅因为害怕没有人能填补他们的位置或满足你生活中的这种社会需求，就紧紧抓住这些关系不放。我认为有很多人某天会突然出现在你的生活里，改变一切。但你确实需要为他们留出空间。而留出空间意味着以下几点。不要抱有“你已经有了你需要的所有朋友”这种哲学。这听起来可能是真的，但你永远不知道。你真的永远不知道向另外多一个人敞开心扉会在多大程度上彻底改变你的一切。此外，即使事情让你感到害怕，也要对各种事情说“不”，对邀请、活动、加入体育俱乐部和新爱好说“不”。采取这样的理念：
everyone wants to be your friend. You are magnetic. You attract really good people. Don't isolate yourself by thinking that you can only be friends with one type of person or that the length of time you've been friends with someone is the only factor in your closeness, is the only kind of indicator of compatibility. I think that we buy into that a lot, that just because we've known someone the longest must mean that they are our best friend. And time and time again, we see that that is not true, that compatibility and chemistry and love and platonic intimacy work in really strange and surprising ways. And with that, do not buy into this idea that you are past your friendship prime.
每个人都想成为你的朋友。你极具吸引力。你吸引的都是非常好的人。不要孤立自己，以为自己只能和一个类型的人做朋友，或者以为与某人做朋友的时间长短是你亲密程度的唯一因素，是兼容性的唯一指标。我认为我们非常相信这一点，即仅仅因为我们认识某人最久，就一定意味着他们是我们最好的朋友。一次又一次，我们发现事实并非如此，兼容性、化学反应、爱和柏拉图式的亲密关系以非常奇怪和惊人的方式运作。顺便说一句，不要相信你已经过了友谊全盛期这种想法。
Because when you believe that there was a time and a place to make your lifelong friends, you've missed it, you've missed the boat, you're subconsciously going to be less likely to initiate new conversations, new connections, new relationships, because you already feel like you've lost. You already feel like you're behind. also think it's very important to not respond with fear when we feel our kind of friendship landscape shifting because fear will have you reacting in ways that are irrational and actually counter to your true intentions, which is to foster deep love with those around you, to feel like you belong.
因为当你相信曾经有一个时间和地点去结交你一生挚友的机会，而你已经错过了，你错过了这艘船时，你在潜意识里就会更不愿意发起新的对话、新的连接、新的关系，因为你已经觉得自己输了。你已经觉得自己落后了。我还认为，当我们感觉到我们的友谊版图在发生变化时，不以恐惧做出回应是非常重要的，因为恐惧会让你做出不理性的反应，这实际上违背了你的真实意图，即与周围的人培养深厚的爱，感受到归属感。
Perceived rejection can really sting, but just because your relationship has changed doesn't mean that it needs to be completely discarded. I think about my friendships at least a lot of the time in terms of levels. You have your top rung, kind of your right or die friendships, then those friends that you maybe wished you saw more, or you're slightly less close to at the moment.
感知到的拒绝确实会很刺痛，但仅仅因为你们的关系发生了变化，并不意味着它需要被完全抛弃。我至少在很多时候都是用等级来思考我的友谊。你有你的最高层，也就是那种生死之交的友谊，然后是那些你可能希望多见几次面，或者目前关系稍微疏远一点的朋友。
You've got your work friends, you've got your acquaintances, who you would very kindly have a chat with in the street and know a little bit about their life, but you're not super close to. And then you have strangers. Maybe this person, this person that you are thinking about right now, this friend, is just sitting at a rung lower than
你有你的职场朋友，你有你的熟人，你会在街上非常友好地和他们聊天，对他们的生活略知一二，但你们并不是超级亲密。然后你有陌生人。也许这个人，你现在想到的这个人，这个朋友，只是比
normal. Does that mean that they need to be completely relegated to the strangers category? Probably not. They're just at a different point in their relationship to you, but you should keep the door open for them to come back in, for them to promote themselves back up to top wrong. obviously this does not apply to friends who have totally crossed boundaries with you or who have treated you terribly but just those who have maybe just have different priorities right now give them the grace that you would want in that situation so i actually have a story about this i have a very very close friend of mine possibly my longest friend and we were incredibly close for the first three or four years that we after we'd met like we did
正常情况低了一层。这是否意味着他们需要被完全贬为陌生人那一类？可能不会。他们只是处于与你关系的不同阶段，但你应该为他们敞开大门，让他们回来，让他们重新晋升到最高层。显然，这不适用于那些完全越界或对你极其恶劣的朋友，而只是那些现在可能有不同优先事项的朋友，给予他们在那种情况下你希望得到的宽容。所以我其实有一个关于这个的故事，我有一个非常非常要好的朋友，可能是认识时间最长的朋友，在我们认识后的前三四年里，我们亲密无间，比如我们
everything together, we knew everything about each other's life. And then we went through this period almost randomly without any context of just like complete disconnect. We saw each other rarely. I really did feel like for certain that the friendship was over. It was really upsetting. It weighed really heavily on my mind. But I didn't want to close the door. And I know that she didn't want to either. And lo and behold, two years on, I think even a little bit longer than that, now, like three or four years on. We are back to that same level of closeness, maybe even closer. She is one of the best people in my life. And I think it's because we gave each other permission, maybe even subconsciously to follow our own paths, that our friendship has allowed to, you know,
做什么都在一起，我们知道彼此生活中的一切。然后我们经历了一段几乎是随机的、没有任何背景的完全失联的时期。我们很少见面。我真的非常确信这段友谊结束了。这真的很让人心烦。它给我的心里带来了沉重的负担。但我不想关上这扇门。我知道她也不想。你看，两年后，甚至比那更久一点，现在大约三四年后。我们又回到了那种亲密程度，甚至可能更亲密。她是我生命中最优秀的人之一。我认为这是因为我们允许彼此，甚至可能是在潜意识里允许彼此走自己的路，我们的友谊才得以，你知道的，
is allowed to be this strong because we've seen it through moments of tension and moments of change. And we knew that either we would come back to each other or we wouldn't. And we would still be incredibly happy for the other person. Change does not mean death. It does not mean the end. The best kinds of friendships change and evolve despite factors like time and proximity. Don't panic. I promise the fear you have is temporary.
得以如此牢固，因为我们一起经历了紧张时刻和改变时刻。我们知道，要么我们会回到彼此身边，要么不会。而我们依然会为对方感到无比的高兴。改变并不意味着死亡。这并不意味着结束。最好类型的友谊会随着时间和空间等因素的推移而改变和演变。不要惊慌。我向你保证，你的恐惧是暂时的。
And alongside that, that fear may also motivate you to make new friends. To go out there and, I don't know. actually put yourself in a position that you haven't had to before. Put yourself in a position where friendship isn't as convenient as it once was, but now you have the opportunity to choose, right? Someone once said to me, I was asking this person, he was like, I don't really have many friends. And I was like, why?
除此之外，这种恐惧也可能会激励你结交新朋友。去外面，我不知道。实际上让自己处于一个你以前不必经历的境地。让自己处于这样一个位置：友谊不像以前那样方便，但现在你有机会做出选择，对吧？曾经有人对我说，我问这个人，他说：“我其实没有很多朋友。”然后我说：“为什么？”
You know, aren't you lonely? Why don't, why wouldn't you want a million friends? And he was like, well, the people around you are who you become. And so I think that it's actually worthwhile. to be a little bit picky when it comes to that. And maybe if you are at a place where you are quite isolated and you're quite lonely, you have seen a lot of friendships change. Instead of viewing it as this like negative, like life-ending thing of like I'm never going
你知道，难道你不孤独吗？为什么不，为什么你不想拥有一百万个朋友呢？他说：“嗯，你身边的人就是你会成为的人。”所以我认为，在这方面挑剔一点其实是值得的。也许如果你处于一个相当孤立、相当孤独的阶段，你看到了很多友谊的改变。与其把它看作是一个负面的、毁灭性的事情，觉得我永远不会
to have what I once had, I'm never going to feel connected or like I belong again. View it as a new beginning. Be like, wow, I get to like, I get to create the life that I want to. here. I get to make the friendships that I would like to make. I get to be surprised by the people who are one day just going to walk in the door and completely change who I am. I think loneliness is just an emotion. It is just a message from our mind telling us what we need. The same way that hunger tells us, you know, that our body needs fuel or thirst tells us that we need hydration. Loneliness and feeling disconnected to people tells you that it's time to reach out.
拥有我曾经拥有的东西，我再也不会感到被连接或有归属感了。把它看作是一个新的开始。你会觉得，哇，我终于可以，我可以在这里创造我想要的生活。我可以结交我想结交的友谊。我可以为那些某天会突然走进门并彻底改变我的人感到惊喜。我认为孤独只是一种情绪。它只是我们大脑发出的告诉我们我们需要什么的信号。就像饥饿告诉我们，你知道的，我们的身体需要燃料，或者口渴告诉我们需要补充水分一样。孤独和与人断联的感觉告诉你，是时候去联系别人了。
And I guess that's my final tip here. Be honest with your friends that you would like to see them more or you would like to chat more often. I did this the other day with my friend Steph where I was like, I'm on the friendship roller coaster right now and I'm at a dip. Can we make time to see each other? And of course she said yes, that openness, that vulnerability is vital here. Because often others in our life don't really know what we're going through. They don't know how we're feeling.
我想这就是我的最后一条建议。对你的朋友诚实，告诉他们你希望更多地见到他们，或者你希望更频繁地聊天。前几天我和我的朋友斯蒂芬就这样做了，我说：“我现在正坐着友谊过山车，我正处于低谷。我们能腾出时间见面吗？”当然她答应了，这种坦诚、这种脆弱在这里至关重要。因为我们生活中的其他人通常并不知道我们正在经历什么。他们不知道我们的感受。
They may not have noticed what we have noticed, that we have drifted. So you can choose to say nothing, or you can choose to be honest with how you feel in that moment. And 90% of the time, the people who truly love you want you to be happy. And they will respond positively to that, and they will make time for you. It is just a matter of reaching out. And you know what? In case I haven't said it enough times, this is not just you.
他们可能没有注意到我们所注意到的，即我们已经疏远了。所以你可以选择什么都不说，或者你可以选择对你当时的感受诚实。90% 的情况下，真正爱你的人希望你快乐。他们会对这一点做出积极的回应，他们会为你腾出时间。这只关乎于去主动联系。你知道吗？如果我还没说够的话，这不仅仅是你。
I know it's hard, change is hard, human beings naturally fear change. Isolation is hard. But do not blame yourself or start to internalize what are actually really common transitions here as a sign that there is something wrong with you or that you are undeserving of good long-lasting friendships. You absolutely are. You just may not have found them yet. I always think of this quote and it brings me so much peace in kind of these moments of catastrophizing. You have a lot of. You have a lot of haven't yet met all the people who you will love in this life. And I think that is so beautiful. How magical is it to imagine all of the people who are now strangers one day being individuals in your life who you won't be able to live without? These people who you will one day meet
我知道这很难，改变很难，人类天生害怕改变。孤立很难。但不要责怪自己，也不要把这些实际上非常普遍的转变内化为自身有问题的信号，或者认为你不配拥有美好的、长久的友谊。你绝对配得上。你可能只是还没找到他们。每当我脑海中浮现这种灾难化的想法时，我总是会想起这句话，它带给我极大的平静。你还有很多。你还有很多尚未在这世上遇到、你会去爱的人。我觉得这太美妙了。想象一下那些现在还是陌生人的人，有一天会成为你生命中不可或缺的个体，这有多么神奇？这些你终将遇到的人
who will tell you the story of the life they are now living. We are so young. Sometimes it's so impossible to really appreciate how young we are. It is not the end of the road. There is so much more love to experience. And like we said, there has been so many studies that have shown that not only is this incredibly common, but a lot of us replace, you know, 50% of our friends, 80% of our friends every seven years. You are just in a transition period right now, along with many, many others, one that you will come out of and you'll be able to look back at and say, I needed that to happen. I needed to see these friendships fade away. I needed to be alone for a while in order to really appreciate how beautiful these new people in my life are.
会向你讲述他们现在正在过着的生活的故事。我们还这么年轻。有时我们真的很难真正体会到我们有多年轻。这不是路的尽头。还有更多的爱等着我们去体验。正如我们所说，有许多研究表明，这不仅极其普遍，而且我们中的许多人每七年就会更换 50% 的朋友、80% 的朋友。你现在正处于一个过渡期，许多其他人也是如此，你会走出这个时期，并且能够回过头来说：“我需要发生这一切。我需要看到这些友谊逐渐淡去。我需要孤独一段时间，才能真正体会到我生命中这些新的人有多么美好。”
So I really hope that this episode has helped normalize this experience for you. I totally understand the fear. Please, I feel like I live this fear every day. So it was actually quite comforting to discuss this and to kind of explore. I think some of the reasons behind why we see that happen. I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. it brought you comfort as always if you feel like there is someone in your life who feels this way who needs to hear this episode please feel free to send them the link to share it along to share
所以我真的希望这一集能够帮助你正常化这种体验。我完全理解这种恐惧。拜托，我觉得我每天都生活在恐惧中。所以讨论这个并探索一下我们看到这种情况发生的一些原因，其实挺让人安慰的。我真的希望你喜欢这一集。它给你带来了安慰。像往常一样，如果你觉得你生命中有谁有这种感觉，谁需要听听这一集，请随时把链接发给他们，分享给他们，将
the love along leave a five-star review if you feel cool to do so and make sure you're following so that you know when new episodes come out if you have an episode suggestion as well please follow us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. I love hearing from you guys. I love hearing about what your 20s has been like. You guys always have the most amazing suggestions for topics I have never considered before. So follow us over there. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode.
这份爱传递下去，如果觉得可以的话，留下五星好评，并确保关注我们，这样你就知道新节目什么时候发布了。如果你也有节目建议，请在 Instagram 上关注我们 @that psychology podcast。我喜欢听你们分享。我喜欢听你们讲述你们的二十多岁是怎么度过的。你们总是能提出我以前从未考虑过的主题的绝妙建议。所以去那里关注我们吧。像往常一样，我们下周会带着另一集回归。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations. that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话。在其他任何地方进行这些对话真的都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听 iHeart 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方的 Learn the hard way。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，
and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
收听《2%》。即 TWA%，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。人类品质保证。本集尚无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。